ça veut ses charmes b est venue d'alou
cet os x
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dont le 7-8
sport nous découvrirons évidemment
jeunes shelton tout à l'heure dans une
page spéciale foot us est tout d'abord
on passe au titre en images de cette
édition
interview du nouveau phénomène des
templiers le jeune quarterback américain
shaun shelton qui a déjà réalisé une
performance de choix ce week-end pour
l'ouverture dû championnat à près de 4
mois après leur dernier succès en
championnat les féminines de l'entente
au chesnay versailles se sont imposés
face à rennes et restent encore en vie
en nationale une
il est le plus vieux joueur de rugby de
france à 74 ans philippe wallraff joue
avec l'équipe loisirs jusqu'à et rugby
rencontre avec un humour un amoureux de
l'ovalie est évidemment en fin
d'émission comme d'habitude tous les
résultats du week-end mais on passe tout
d'abord à la voile on s'envole en mer
avec le navigateur illinois benoît
verbeek
benoît verbeek bonsoir font évoluer en
catégorie 6 1 quand on va en parler vous
nous expliquer un petit peu le concept
de cette catégorie vous êtes navigateurs
solitaires
de surcroît vous préparer deux régates
dont la régate qui va se dérouler à
l'été 2014 cette année sables les açores
les sables
tout d'abord pour essayer de mieux vous
connaître car un navigateur dans les
yvelines c'est plutôt peu commun comment
vous est venue cette passion de la
navigation un peu par hasard en fait
c'était à 14 ans dans le cadre d'une
colonie de vacances les ctd colonies à
thème et pour des raisons priorisation
fait le choix que j'avais fait n'avait
pas été retenu
du coup je suis tombé sur des des choix
que j'avais mis un peu par hasard vous
départ voulait faire du vtt ski sur
herbe
et puis je j'avais émis un peu par
hasard dessin et c'est le thème qui a
été retenu dans l'est dans les
différentes priorisation et par chance
en fait le site ne faisait pas que des
dessins il faisait aussi la voile et
c'est comme ça qu'en fait j'ai découvert
la voile ça m'a tout de suite passionné
et puis un point qu'au bout de trois
semaines
mallet les moniteurs me laisser prendre
en main un bateau avec cinq autres
personnes de mon âge dans la rade de
brest
vous aviez à l'époque 14 ans vous faites
votre première compétition en 2007 c'est
donc vous naviguez sur un 6,50 pour nos
téléspectateurs
qu'est ce que cela veut dire alors si 56
tout simplement la longueur du bateau
donc les minis 6 50 sont des bateaux de
6 mètres cinquante de long 3 m de large
donc très large
ils ressemblent un peu à des bateaux du
vendée globe en trois fois plus petit et
ils répondent à une jauge open
c'est-à-dire que dans le règlement de
construction tout ce qui n'est pas
interdit est autorisé donc ça laisse un
peu de marge pour les coureurs pour les
architectes et c'est ça en fait aussi
une vitrine technologique pour les plus
gros bateaux alors il faut le dire aussi
cette catégorie de 6,50 c'est un petit
peu le b à ba de la navigation tous les
grands navigateurs qui on le connaît
michel desjoyeaux jean pierre dick sont
passés par là exactement où
je vais annoncer un chiffre de 80% on
doit pas être très loin parce que c'est
une catégorie où on n'a pas le droit à
la communication qu'on se retrouve face
aux fondamentaux de la navigation
on parle de pmv pression nuages vent et
il faut faire avec ça et simplement
bulletin météo qu'on reçoit par la radio
et toute communication avec la terre est
interdite donc vous je le rappelle vous
n'avez gagné donc en solitaire
vous avez une particularité en tout cas
votre bateau c'est qu'il est 100%
autonome en énergie expliqué dans un
petit peu le concept parce que c'est
quand même assez rare non oui bah en
fait c'est le premier en tout cas qui
répondent à ce critère
en fait depuis la mise à l'eau du bateau
donc 2007
je ne consomme aucun carburant quel
qu'il soit que ce soit pour
l'électricité du bord pour
l'électronique de navigation pour faire
chauffer de l'eau rouge une bouilloire
électrique et même pour le moteur
électrique puisque j'utilise pour tout
ça uniquement l'énergie produite par les
panneaux solaires du bateau de l'état
depuis sept ans de vous est venue cette
idée de faire un bateau écolo s'il va se
dire ben c'est encore à une anecdote en
fait c'est au moment où je réfléchissais
me lancer dans cette catégorie qui me
plaisait
pas mal sur le papier il y avait eu un
vendée globe où jean pierre dick
en rentrant dans le grand sud avait
perdu son générateur et dû faire toute
la course uniquement avec ses panneaux
solaires a fini 5e nous passent très
oral et de là est sortie l'idée dans un
journal spécialisé de la voile très
connu l'idée d'un bateau entièrement
autonome en énergie et les deux mis
ensemble même si tiens c'est amusant
j'ai essayé de me lancer là dedans et ça
donner un peu de sens ou à la pratique
ça répondait à mes ma curiosité mais on
soucis de fin mon envie de technologie
de et donc du coup voilà je me suis
lancé comme ça je le disais à vous
préparer plusieurs courses notamment une
en 2014 les sables les açores les sables
j'imagine qu'on ait navigateur à votre
niveau la préparation ça doit être
compliqué à élaborer parce qu'il faut
pouvoir naviguer en même temps il ya une
préparation physique et d'autres
paramètres non oui c'est ça mais il ya
beaucoup de paramètres et déjà il le à
voile reste un sport mécanique donc faut
avant tout préparé le bateau est prêt à
savoir gérer toutes les éventualités
ensuite pour la préparation physique
la région est idéal la vallée de
chevreuse pour le vélo c'est vraiment
c'est pas une mecque mais en tout cas
c'est une région très propice et puis
après pour tous qui navigue à sion je me
déplace sur la rochelle là où se trouve
le centre d'entraînement dans lequel
je navigue et où se trouve le bateau
pour participer à ces courses
il ya évidemment une condition
sinequanone c'est l'aspect financier il
ya encore un aspect important chez vous
un peu particulier puisque là vous
faites appel au financement participatif
c'est ça j'ai trouvé avec l'idée du parc
de chevreuse donc qui me soutient pour
promouvoir le projet l'idée intéressante
parce qu en fait le financement partie
phase iib participatif ce n'est ni moins
que du sponsoring élargi revisitée et
adaptée pour les financements de
particulier le autant des entreprises
chercheront des retours en images au
temps des particuliers cherchent
comprend déjà pas de donner des sommes
aussi importantes et cherchons des
retours plus personnalité plus
personnalisés ça peut être des souvenirs
personnalisé d accès vip des choses
comme ça sur les pontons et donc du coup
de perdre le financement participatif
permet ça alors votre campagne a été
lancée le 7 février sa cour pour 90
jours donc on aura le résultat fin mai
si vous avez votre financement il vous
faut à peu près combien alors le
financement sera réussie validé par kiss
kiss bang bang
si on atteint et 6000 euros sachant que
le budget total pour la saison et 10000
euros dernière question on dit souvent
que les navigateurs sont des sportifs un
petit peu à part entière dans
du sport c'est un peu votre cas aussi en
mer alors ça c'est une grande question à
part entière il y a un aspect solitude
qui est important il ya aussi la gestion
de la fatigue qui fait qu' on prend on
fait les choses peut-être plus lentement
quand on est en maître en mer
l'inadaptation milieu marin et qui est
assez importante et effectivement au
bout de dix jours 20 jours en mer on est
complètement déphasé par rapport à la
vie terrienne manqué une sorte d'
acclimatation un retour à la vie
terrienne qui est pas anodin gérer c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'on nous dit un peu
à part mais c'est plus une adaptation au
milieu qui fait que quand on nous
rencontre juste avant ou juste après les
courses on ne peut paraître décalé très
bien merci beaucoup benoît d'être passés
sur le 7-8 sport je rappelle que l'on
peut vous soutenir donc via votre site
internet gullivers www.tunisair.com pour
vous faire un petit don et participer un
petit peu à cette future régate
si je peux rajouter un dernier mot le
mini à cette caractéristique justement
de d'être sans communication avec la
terre ce qui fait que les paroles des
coureurs sont attendus et rarement
rarement une intéressante puisque 20 jou
10 20 jours sans parler ça forcément
quand on se met alors à corps a raconté
c'est en général très intense et pour ça
il est rare que des investisseurs que
ceux des entreprises des particuliers
soient déçus de leur investissement très
bien merci beaucoup benoît et qui on
suivra évidemment cette campagne et puis
votre votre regard toute prochaine merci
beaucoup merci
il est le plus vieux joueur de rugby de
france
à 74 ans philippe val rave jouer avec
l'équipe loisirs du sky rugby malgré la
polémique sur toute récente sur l'âge
limite des joueurs la petite star des
troubadours combien encore inscrire
quelques essais avant de raccrocher les
crampons
philippe val rave est un costaud
douzième enfant d'une famille de
maréchaux ferrants nordistes à 74 ans ce
deuxième ligne de l'équipe loisirs des
troubadours ne loupent quasiment jamais
une rencontre
et pourtant lorsqu'il découvre le rugby
à l'âge de 20 ans l'ovalie ne lui parlez
pas trop je le comprenais rien à ce jeu
et m'ont amené là
on dit bon tu te mets là pour une touche
tu sautes tu prends la balle j'ai sauté
j'ai pris là bas noté partez pas
malhabile qui nous plaît et puis meurent
entraîné depuis resté dans le rugby
depuis la sphère francis baiona ce
pilier de 68 ans privé de licence en
raison de son âge trop avancé
tous les regards se tournent vers ramsès
pas d'inquiétude pour autant car tous
les ans son médecin signe la licence de
cet ancien ingénieur les yeux fermés mon
médecin qui est de montigny est un
excellent médecin m'a bien dit bon fils
et petits continuent mais fait quand
même attention parce que non tu prends
des risques
mais tant que les avantages sont dépasse
largement les risques et à voix ne pas
prendre trop de risques
donc c'est une question de précaution
faut juste le voir pour le voir pour le
croire quoi 74 ans est à fond comme ça
j'avoue que je sais pas j'y serai comme
et puis chaque fois que tu le tout le
temps paul un petit peu c'est cesser ce
genre de mec à dire attendez les gars je
parle bibelots quoi il n'y a pas de
problème malaisie quoi c'est l'homme ce
à quoi la saison dernière avec sa
licence toujours tamponné compétition il
a même joué 20 minutes avec la réserve
du sky rugby en championnat d'honneur
mais il y a deux ans un adversaire le
plaquent assez violemment ramsès reste
ko
ça m'a fait très peur donc maintenant je
joue proche des gros l'apprendre des
chocs en face ça me fait pas peur mais
je fais plus le
je veux pas le mariole toujours un peu
dans les affaires comme on généreux du
club ce joueur pas comme les autres
organisera un grand tournoi l'an
prochain en dordogne où il possède une
bicoque qu'il retape pour ses vieux
jours
à sa sortie du prix shelton shon peux-tu
te présenter pour nos téléspectateurs
je m'appelle shelton j'ai 22 ans je
viens de terminer mes études
universitaires et maintenant je joue au
poste de quarterback pour les templiers
d'elancourt
et c'est cool d'être là what is quel est
ton parcours dans le foot us
j'ai commencé à jouer au foot au foot
américain à l'âge de six ans et j'ai
tout de suite adoré cela et tout de
suite j'ai su que je voulais faire du
football la priorité numéro un de ma vie
j'ai commencé à jouer dans un petit
championnat puis au lycée à partir de 14
ans jusqu'à l'âge de 18 ans puis quand
je suis entré à l'université j'ai
évidemment continuer et j'ai pu jouer
pour une équipe universitaire et lorsque
j'ai été diplômé je me suis dit que je
ne pouvais pas arrêter le football
tant que j'aurai des opportunités pour
jouer je jouerai surtout tant que mon
corps me le permettra le football en fin
de compte c'est un peu toute ta vie non
quand j'aurai terminé ma carrière
j'aimerais vraiment entraîné et je
pourrai revenir ici à elancourt car
cette saison j'entraîne déjà les juniors
je fais vraiment ce que j'aime et je
n'ai pas à me plaindre qu au lieu des
scribes tu nous décrire l'image qu'a le
foot américain aux états unis à la nfl
aux états unis est tout simplement ancré
dans notre culture c'est un peu
comparable ici en france à la passion
qu'ont les gens pour les équipes de
football à berne
à tous les gens ont une passion pour ce
sport
ils sont supporters d'une équipe ils
font dans les bars il regarde les matchs
ils les analysent ensemble oui le
football est vraiment ancré dans chaque
américain
tout simplement ils aiment ça ce n'est
pas du tout le même système en france
non il n'y a que des équipes
professionnelles là bas c'est le chemin
basique à l'université il vous recrutent
et passent de nombreux tests physiques
c'est vraiment un système professionnel
et quand tu joues pour l'une de ces
équipes c'est ton travail et tu fais ça
à plein temps tu passe de nombreuses
heures par semaine à faire de la vidéo
alors qu'ici c'est encore en
développement qui ne peut pas encore
vivre de ce sport alors qu'aux états
unis qui te fait beaucoup plus d'argent
qu'il nous faut pour en vivre
je parle de contrat de 15 à 20 millions
de dollars par an à peu près autant que
le football ici en français le stade
domec
ici tous mes coéquipiers ont un autre
métier que le foot us et par amour de ce
sport ils viennent ici s'entraîner deux
fois par semaine et donne quatre heures
de leur temps et beaucoup le week-end
c'est la grosse différence va revenir
aux templiers
pourquoi as tu choisi ils ont cours à
vos absences
ouais vous savez j'avais plus d'options
quand j'avais le portrait de venir ici
en france concernant l on court j'ai
discuté avec l'entraîneur maniche arrêt
et je me suis aperçu qu'il y avait une
grosse différence entre elancourt et les
autres équipes france
l'encours l'objectif prioritaire est de
gagner le championnat
tout le monde est tourné vers cet
objectif tout le monde ici veut ce titre
chez les autres on me disait on espère
faire une belle saison est très
compétitif
voilà la grande différence entre
elancourt et les autres équipes
concrètement quels sont tes objectifs
cette saison avec les templiers gagner
le championnat français
alors je n'ai pas vraiment d'objectif
personnel je n'en ai jamais en vérité je
veux juste gagner les huit matches du
championnat
c'est le plus important je pense que
tout le monde serait déçu si on ne
gagnait pas le championnat
et moi aussi tu sais que tu passes
derrière vini roth
c'est un beau challenge de lui succéder
le big wet challenger oui ce que j'ai
entendu sur lui c'est que c'est un super
mec
mais c'est aussi un super quarterbacks
qui était tout près de devenir le
meilleur joueur du championnat je
comprends qu'il était un joueur phare du
championnat
je sais que j'ai une grande
responsabilité pour relever sa
succession ici et améliorer ce qu'il a
déjà fait pour toi il encourait une
étape dans sa progression
oui quand je joue à l'université je
disais souvent que je voulais continuer
de jouer autant que possible et ici
c'est une nouvelle expérience pour moi
c'est vraiment l'occasion pour moi de
progresser pas seulement en tant que
joueur mais aussi en tant qu'entraîneur
communiquer avec les gens malgré la
barrière de la langue
et c'est un gros défi pour un entraîneur
une dernière question est ce que tu te
plais à elancourt oui oui c'est
tellement différent de tout ce que j'ai
connus auparavant
je suis vraiment heureux ici et j'essaie
de devenir un bon français c'est une
super expérience personnelle
sur de nombreux plans hockey fun ce lot
cendre sur le parquet du gymnase bélair
ce week-end souffler comme un air de
survie les féminines de l'entente le
chesnay-versailles 10e n'avait pas le
droit à l'erreur face au 11e rennes en
mode commando les yvelinoises entame
parfaitement la rencontre menée par une
cécile dansèrent impérial dans la
raquette auteur de 17 points 27 14 après
le premier quart temps mais le deuxième
acte sera celui des rennaises comme
souvent cette saison les yvelinoises
voient leur matelas diminué pour rentrer
aux vestiaires avec trois petits points
d'avancé 35 32
les coéquipières de virginie aurensan
entame le dernier quart-temps de dans le
panier un tout simplement avec le viseur
en tête et reprennent 14 points d'avance
les yvelinoises avaient l'occasion de
terminer la rencontre en roue libre mais
c'était sans compter sur la révolte des
rennaises qui au prix d'un bel effort
recolle à 2 petits points à deux minutes
du buzzer les yvelinois s'impose
finalement 71 à 64 elles restent
onzièmes de leur poule mais on retrouve
la victoire après quatre mois sans
succès l'opération commando a donc
fonctionné dur et long comme tous nos
matches depuis le début de l'année
on a perdu 80% de nos matchs en 3 8
points toujours sur le même scénario là
on a tenu le match du début à la fin
avec un très beau premier quart temps
c'est ce qui est important au 27 points
à deuxième quart-temps beau plutôt moyen
mais bon on a les filles ont fait le
travail ce soir et c'est très bien on
est en mode commando sur tous les matchs
maintenant et s'est passé ce soir voilà
on a mis les lancers francs alors que
d'habitude on met pas les lancers francs
on a provoqué un petit peu la chance
c'était très bien allez on passe aux
autres résultats du week-end
ce week-end le championnat de france
élite de foot us reprenait ses droits et
pour cette première journée les
templiers d'elancourt se déplacer chez
les kangourous de pessac et les joueurs
d'emmanuel charest se sont largement
imposés 59,21 avec 70 ch dans à la clé
un excellent shon shelton les
audincourtois envoie donc un message
clair à tous leurs concurrents au
classement avec trois points d'avancé et
surtout trois points depuis le début de
la saison tout simplement les templiers
son deuxième à la différence des deux
points derrière les black panthers
champion de france en titre
en football européen cette fois ci
disait 17e journée de division d'honneur
versailles est allé s'imposer sur la
pelouse des ulis à 1 0 les versaillais
sont cinquièmes de leur poule en
promotion d'honneur 15e journée
guyancourt et unis se sont séparés sur
un match nul 1 partout le sg remonte à
la 9e place dans la poule b la rencontre
entre trappe et noisy le grand a été
reportée chez les femmes 14e journée de
division 2 et nouvelle défaite pour
montigny qui s'est lourdement incliné à
algrange 6 buts à 1
lésigny monteyne sont toujours lanterne
rouge de leur poule en rugby les pour le
compte de la 16e journée de fédérale 3
plaisir deuxième accueillez le quatrième
chartres si les joueurs de philibert
sont cueillis à froid a mené rapidement
15 3 ils réagissent très vite dans la
première période par deux fois dont cet
essai collectif que vous allez voir
initiée sur une touche à 15 mètres de
l'en but mais avant plaisir wa forme
tamoul inarrêtable et edward le prieur
termine le travail au retour des
vestiaires les joueurs du prc et peuvent
compter sur le pied de leur jeune demi
de mêlée qui donnera de l'air aux jaune
et bleu sur ce drop que vous venez de
voir
score final 26 à 15 je vous propose
d'écouter l'entraîneur philippe behar
plutôt satisfait de la performance de
ses joueurs je reproche à jamais aux
joueurs de tenter beaucoup de choses
parce que c'est le jeu c'est le projet
de jeu qu'on a mis en place le jeu qu'on
veut réaliser après bon bah c'est sûr
que l'on n'est qu'en fédérale 3 donc il
ya des fautes de main le jeu appelle les
fautes mais je préfère qu'on fasse
tomber x ballon est contente
beaucoup de volume parce que
l'adversaire on a bien vu au bout d'un
moment l'adversaire était à la rue
complètement et c'est vrai que c'est
comme ça qu'on sera capable je veux dire
de de jouer vraiment ce haut de tableau
et peut-être d'aller jouer des matchs de
monter coin en basket championnat de
france de nationale 3 18e journée après
deux défaites consécutives trappe à
renouer avec la victoire face au paris
levallois score succès évidemment 68 à
49 les trappistes reste neuvième de son
côté l'entente le chesnay-versailles 7e
s'est logiquement incliné sur le parquet
du cinquième gennevilliers 78 à 53 en
tennis de table 3e journée du
championnat par équipe de national une
féminine et troisième défaite pour
l'entendre voisin saint-arnoult privés
de leur pépite veeren fritsch 20 sont
les joueuses de geoffrey nisand se sont
inclinés face à béthune lui match à
trois ce week end des clayes sous bois
accueillait la cinquième édition de
l'ipl dont on parlait la semaine
dernière concours international
d'aéromodélisme les meilleurs pilotes du
monde et leurs maquettes ont encore
proposer des prestations spectaculaires
il était jugé à la fois sur l'épreuve
des figures imposées ou le jury note la
qualité technique et la géométrie mais
aussi sur du volant musique comparable
au programme libre en au programme libre
en patinage artistique où les avions
propose un véritable ballet aérien un
pilotage exigent toutefois qui requiert
quelques aptitudes il faut avoir de bons
réflexes d'excellents réflexes parce que
de temps en temps dans l'avion va pas
faire exactement ce qu'il faut donc il
faut avoir de très bons réflexes
avec la télécommande
mais c'est surtout une question
d'entraînement à force de faire et puis
surtout savoir construire aussi parce
que souvent ça casse donc il faut savoir
reconstruire
nous l'avions nous vous l'avions fait
découvrir la saison dernière la
marcheuse du smac véronique cochereau
triple médaillé aux championnats
d'europe vétérans 2012 a décroché ce
week-end son quatrième titre de
championne de france de marche
athlétique en salle et en battant en
plus son record personnel en 16 minutes
7 secondes et 31 centièmes l'athlète du
club bini montain se tournent désormais
vers les championnats du monde qui
auront lieu à budapest fin mars est
toujours en athlétisme mais en élite
cette fois la hurdleuse de l'entente
athlétique de saint quentin en yvelines
aïe c'est à diawara et glaner une belle
médaille d'argent ce week-end aux
championnats de france en salle sur le
60 m haies c'est sa sixième médaille sur
les championnats nationaux pour finir ce
set 8 ports évidemment votre agenda du
week-end de rendez vous à ne pas rater
tout d'abord du foot us deuxième journée
du championnat de france élite premier
match à domicile des templiers qui
recevront les molosses d'asnières coup
d'envoi à 20 heures et à 20 heures
également ce samedi du roller hockey 11e
journée de nationale 2 et l'encours
reçoit la 2 et le deuxième villeneuve
pour tenter de décrocher une deuxième
victoire cette saison coup d'envoi comme
je le disais à 20 heures c'est la fin de
ce set 8 fort merci encore une fois de
l'avoir suivi excellente soirée sur tv
fidh à lundi prochain